[Music]
[Applause]
ESPN NBA analysts former NBA player JJ
Redick joining us on behalf of
DraftKings appreciate you uh spending
some time with us there JJ let me ask
you the poll question here I'd rather
have my team get swept in a series or
lose in dramatic fashion in game seven
that's interesting
losing seven
of course
have you had both
uh I don't yeah I I was swept when I
played against uh the heels when I was
with Milwaukee briefly
and I'd much rather lose in seven
well if you're LeBron and the Lakers you
could have won maybe two or three of
those games but you still got swept it
didn't feel like a sweep
does that feel like hey we had a great
season if you're the Lakers
given where they started and given the
amount of time post-trade deadline look
I would be very encouraged if I was the
Lakers there's a way to create some cap
space uh they've got to bring Brett back
Austin Reeves I thought his development
this year into a legit legit uh half
court shot Creator
um you know you could run offense throw
him I thought that was a huge
development and you know LeBron you know
I'm assuming he's going to have some
sort of surgery and Rehab from Matt so
maybe he's not fully 100 when the season
starts but there's enough to build on
this this based on this this season and
this postseason run but yeah you're
right that series was look you got to
give Denver credit because there's a
better team have the best player in the
world they closed out games ridiculous
shot making down the stretch key stops
in game four you got to give them credit
uh but the Lakers aren't that far off
uh we had uh Tim legler on yesterday
said it doesn't matter who's going to
play the nuggets the nuggets are going
to win because there is nobody who's
come up with a game plan to stop Joker
what do you think of that
I think that's accurate
um and it's interesting the last 17
games of the season they went 7-10 they
sat some guys out they had a couple
multiple multi-game losing streaks and
it didn't feel like they had that
momentum so to speak going into the
playoffs and then within a couple games
in the playoffs you're kind of looking
around and you're like wait a minute
this theme is really good and by the end
of the Phoenix series it's it's pretty
clear that they were playing better than
anyone else in the playoffs and it's not
just jokish the game plan I haven't seen
I haven't seen a
game plan to stop the jokic Murray
two-man game whether that's dribble
handoffs or whether that's pick and
rolls they inverted the pick and rolls
at the end of game three they ran Murray
as the screener and jokic is the ball
handler they scored on every play uh
they present so many problems and
there's no good answer
I said this to legler I thought that the
MVP of that Series against the Lakers
was Jamal Murray I knew what to expect
out of jokic Murray though felt like he
went back to the bubble and his version
um
you know do we sort of take Joker for
granted that he's going to give you a
triple double but Jamal Murray can help
you win a title
jokic was the MVP but Murray this the
greatest thing that Michael Malone said
I was calling one of their games earlier
in the playoffs and he referred to Jamal
Murray as the other superhero and I
think that's accurate where look you
have star players they need a robin a
Batman needs a robin you also need some
Alfred's um occasionally you might eat a
Catwoman
um sometimes you need Lucius Fox to step
in but Jamal Murray is a true Robin he's
a true number two reliable can get you a
bucket on his own you can play the
two-man game with with jokic and I I
keep going back to this you know when
you talk about Duos in the NBA the best
duo is always compliment each other and
those two guys compliment each other in
Spades well do Jalen Brown and Jason
Tatum compliment each other
absolutely not I mean I've said this how
much two-man action can you run with
those guys the problem is those two guys
are going to be guarded by the two best
Wing Defenders so anything you do with
the two of them is just going to be a
switch whereas with a jokish Murray pick
and roll or a Draymond stuff pick and
roll
um you've got a lot of uh possible
answers and none of them are really good
we're talking to JJ Redick the former
NBA player and out analyst for the
mothership up for uh at least one
coaching vacancy it feels like uh what
where did this come from wanting to
maybe be a head coach
well I I mean you certainly uh you
certainly missed the competitive side of
professional basketball when you retire
and that's probably the biggest itch
um I'm loving what I'm doing right now
and I'm in a very fortunate situation
that I
um can kind of wait and just see if
there's anything that materializes
that's that's uh that's sort of a
perfect fit
um but you know I've I've talked with
teams now going on a year about
assistant jobs and I'm interested in
being a head coach I don't I don't have
to start as a head coach I don't have to
start a new assistant it doesn't matter
to me it's more just about the the fit
and the the people that are you know at
the organization
um the jomarance situation JJ that this
is the second go-around it feels like
there's anger but then there's also of
you know maybe there's something else
here how does the NBA approach it a
second time around with John Morant
um again I don't I'm not privy to the
conversations between Adam and jaw and
and Jaws team so I I don't want to like
speculate on that
um I would just say it's very clear that
there needs to be structure in place
protocols in place requirements in place
um you know whether that is talking to
someone I mean I'm someone that's been
very open about my own mental health and
my own uh forays into therapy and
performance coaching and all of that and
you know I think we all need it and it
doesn't matter if you're 23 33 63
there's always some self-improvement you
can get and in John's case
um you know I I think having structure
having protocols haven't required having
a clear understanding of consequences
which it didn't sound like after Adam
and Malika had talked at the at the
draft lottery didn't sound like there
was necessarily sort of a clear thing it
was more just about dealing with the
first incident and coming up with uh
with a uh uh a punishment there
um and I'm not I'm not condoning jaw
I've said this a million times I'm not
condoning the behavior he either
deserves to be some punishment in place
and you have to recognize that he's
potentially one of the faces of the new
NBA once LeBron and Steph age out at
some point whenever that may be yeah
uh final 30 seconds you're the GM of the
Lakers and the one move you need to make
in the off season is
um
first of all you hachimura and Reeves
need to come back you need to figure out
a way to bring them back and if you can
create enough cap space I think
upgrading at the point guard position is
probably it and I don't know that the
solution is Kyrie Irving uh because to
get to probably his number you you've
got to relinquish some depth and as we
found out in the playoffs
you know you're only as good as your
weakest link and and that's where I
think a team like the Denver Nuggets
when they went to this eight-man
rotation seven-man rotation at times in
the Conference Finals they don't have a
weak link you know they have
interchangeable parts when they go to
their bench Bruce Brown has been awesome
so I don't know that you want to give up
a ton of depth to go out and sign a Max
Level point guard but that's the
position of me where I think they can
make some Headway
safe travels great to talk to you again
thanks for joining us
JJ Redick joining us on behalf of
DraftKings